des moutons accompagnés de leurs bergère
remplacent les assourdissantes tondeuse
à gazon à essence dans ce parc du
nord-est de montréal
les moutons sont résulte il pour tondre
le gazon fertilise le sol aussi font pas
de compactage comme peuvent le faire dès
la machinerie lourde des bus partant de
sa fait pas de bruit
cette méthode d'entretien écologiques
s'appelle l'écopâturage urbain ce n'est
pas nouveau à montréal des expériences
comme celle là ont déjà eu lieu il ya
quelques années au parc maisonneuve et
au parc pélican entre eux et l'activité
a aussi un volet éducatif sera un projet
de 2 ou là c'est pas un projet de deux
fermes c'est vraiment de projet wii
éducatif
les réactions sont extraordinaires l'a
déjà depuis l'arrivée des moutons c'est
une belle façon site se reconnecter avec
la nature avec même notre passé agricole
donc je sens beaucoup beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé beaucoup de fierté de la
part des citoyens
c'est bon pour la la mentalité pour tout
le monde parce que avec le co vite là çà
çà çà les moutons oui oui oui
et j'aimerais c'est non seulement qu'ils
mettent plus d'animaux ça serait fun
pour les enfants ça crée un événement du
pays
c'est bien
l'initiant social permet de calmer les
gens on voit tout et sourire des gens
quand ils arrivent à proximité ils
voient les moutons bon il ya des
écritures mais aussi les lie les gens
sont super contents amont ils disent et
les épiciers pour les enfants mais on
voit les adultes qui qui sourit tout
autant un projet pilote de quatre
semaines
peu coûteux pour les contribuables est
bénéfique pour la planète et sans doute
aussi pour le moral
une bonne tartine bonne pauvres venus
pour quelqu'un qui travaille de la
maison c'est très très beau issigeac
bissonnet radio-canada bon verre